[Music]
Runk kovina California that's Southern
Southern California I'll be there
October 12th 13th and 14th Cina
California at the LA Factory going to
work on some new material this is not
the Don't Push Me Tour coming out and
check me out uh and uh then I'll be in
Pittsburgh and Cleveland and Detroit
October 20 October 20 areas 20 something
then November 10th Orlando Fort Meers I
got a bunch of spots Baltimore
Philadelphia then I just uh booked these
shows Oxnard California December in
December so go to chris.com for all your
tickets uh uh and the auction one will
be new material as well um that being
said we also have absolutely some
beautiful beautiful merch uh if you want
to go and get some
merch all you got to do is just go to
the merch uh chia.com and we've got go
ahead and join our cult the T-shirt the
hot t-shirt that is absolutely flying
off the shelves the flannel is beautiful
we've got it in medium large extra large
and 2x large if you're a fatty join our
cult flannel exper it's a join our cult
flannel experience that's what we call
that we've got the t-shirts too we've
got a join our cult and share ideas
t-shirt which is absolutely beautiful
medium large extra large 2x large and
three large if you're a fatty boom
batty and we've got our popular oops
buttons without further Ado let's get
into it it's the new and improved
episode of
[Music]
congratulations hey heyo hey
hey No Diggity white um
heyo hey yo hey y
hey
[Music]
no so anyway dude I'm just feeling
musical you know and I'm not a musical
guy dude I don't really understand what
the deal is turned on some t i and I did
it the day before I turned on some Tupac
I was this is some did it the day before
the man who K well supposedly allegedly
who uh got charged with murdering
Tupac the man who the man who is a
former gang leader so that dude do you
understand I think about Tupac every day
for
since 1996 so that's crazy you know I
love Tupac right you know I'm the kind
of guy who absolutely loves Tupac
dude rude but we love
Tupac
um so uh and so
um isn't this crazy dude this is 30
years later 30 years later and the man
is charged a man is charged with murder
in the TX sh cour case the man a former
gang leader named Dwayne Keith
Davis um all honestly terrible names if
I'm being honest Dwayne Keith and
Davis the four he has said the four
shots that killed the rapper 196 came
from the vehicle he was riding in
incriminated himself um was on a podcast
incriminating himself also wrote a book
about it incriminated himself um more
than 25 years after the killing of Tupac
Shore became a defining tragedy in hipop
this is from The New York Times uh the
man dway K has said in interviews and a
memoir that he was in front in the front
passenger seat of the white Cadillac
that pulled up near the vehicle holding
Mr Shakur uh after
1996 um shot four times and died in a
hospital so okay so he said he did so
why'd he do that hm bad crook um the
worst crook of all time did you do it
yes clink ah
[__] um this is pretty
crazy uh I don't despite the plentiful
speculation and evidence and Reporting
across nearly three decades no charge of
field this is crazy bro yo he changed
history do you know what I mean if he
did it he admitted it but if he did it
but you know he admitted it but it's
like
um in 2019 Memoir Mr Davis who goes by
the name Keith
D worse name um the only the only way to
make the name Keith worse is to call
yourself
Keith it's like Calvin would say it ke
uh recounted a gang dispute that
escalated after Mr shur Andis beat up Mr
Davis's nephew okay so see I knew that
this was part of it I've watched all the
documentaries on it all of them dude and
I knew it was somebody who had something
to do with the fight dude I'm a
detective [__] yeah man I ain't got no
mother I know this stuff I'm smart okay
and I knew it was something to do with
that [__] it's too bad I didn't work for
the police man if I did dude God we
would have [__] nipped this in the
bud a year or two
later
mother so rude to start a song like that
but
okay
um he said them jumping on my nephew
gave us the Ultimate Green Light to do
something H sir incriminating dude Mr
Davis said in the Memoir Compton Street
Legend Tupac chose the wrong game to
play I mean dude you
know that's weird dude gangsters just
think that they are gangster than now
you know what I mean more
gangsteryoutube you know what I mean
ain't nobody bigger than the streets dog
ain't nobody bigger ain't nobody better
than the streets ain't nobody better
than the hood you ever see those like
you know documentaries or like the the
the what do you call not necessarily the
documentaries but the um well I guess so
the docu serieses or something like
Gangland or something and they just have
a guy on camera and he's just like yo
hell yeah I killed 12 people when I used
to roll with them you know what I mean
um [__] I was the muscle
[__] had to get dealt with you
know and it's just like
hey get
them you know I don't understand hey hey
hey ho
hey get him dude hey documentarian call
911 hey boom guy call the
police hey craft
service call the
authorities hey hey grip tell the media
hey get
him you know I mean back in the when I
was in the rolling Crips or something is
that a thing I basically um killed nine
people dog it's this people here's a
list shows these are their pictures you
know what I mean and then it's just like
Onis Discovery hey
producers get
them you know what I mean
I don't know it's
crazy it's pretty crazy um so anyway
they're gonna get this guy ah this
guy I don't know um Mr Davis said
avoided directly naming the person who
opened fire in recent
interviews um but in a tape confession
released by the former LAPD detective
who investigated Mr
uh Dr Mr Davis told said it had been Mr
Anderson his nephew who was known by
baby Lane see I knew this I I read about
this already I saw the
documentary Mr Anderson was questioned
by officers in 1998 but then he died
right I think Mr Anderson died
um and his M Mr Davis who has also been
known as Kei D said that after the
shooting the men abandoned the car and
walked back to the hotel picking the
vehicle up and uh okay I mean this guy
just basically
said wow okay so did it anyway got
him this is like when R Kelly sang that
song I admitted I did it and it wasn't
about that but it was actually about
that you
know um this is a wild thing man I can't
believe that that's I can't believe that
that's done all right cool
well it's such a crazy time dude my wife
wants to go see that movie The Creator
and I'm just like okay fine but it's
gonna I knew it was going to bomb dude
just like
Barbie and uh Denzel Washington uh who
is in it whatever his name is Marty
Washington and um he's Jewish and um
Marty Washington Ste and so he's in it
and
like AI is tripping people out I think a
bomb because people are scar Eric
Griffin said this people are scared of
AI and I think that it's true I think
it's real it's kind of weird that we're
seeing it and we're like we don't want
to go see it remember when monster
movies were big because everyone thought
the world was going to end or some [__]
I read a thing on it I don't know I'm an
idiot but like they were like they were
like monster movies are big because of
the fear in America that and and all
across the world that is happening
because of something I saw a [__]
article or read a [__] thing or saw a
documentary and [__] and now and that's
what they said basically and so now it's
like everyone's scared of AI but the AI
movies aren't popping because that [__]
is really real there are no monsters
it's not a way to get away and relieve
yourself of the fear it's a way to go
and see oh this is really what's
happening now well isn't that crazy
dude um and somei use is for good and uh
you know I guess it's like you get to
learn stuff and and uh like we got one
of those uh LG standby me big tablet
things and Calvin just plays the games
on that it's crazy they're pretty wild
but uh and then you got uh Tom Hanks
says that it's not really him selling
dental insurance and Instagram ads you
know hey we know unless it's in Japan
dude I if you go to Italy you will see
straight up Tom Hardy doing a [__]
uh like a an ad for a
restaurant he'll just be like yeah I py
me a [__] bag for it here look here's
the here's the here's the dental
insurance thing
here Tom Tom Hanks beware there's a
video out there promoting some dental
plan with an AI version of me I have
nothing to do with it Tom Hanks signs
everything you
know
um so let me see
it can't find it wow dude that's crazy
can't find it because that's how strong
he is That's How Strong Tom Hanks is
it's so obviously not him bro he's like
so handsome and his teeth are [__]
killing
it you can't do comments on Tom Hanks uh
Instagram because every you know there's
like [__] 10% of people on Reddit
thinks he eats kids so he had to had to
shut that down so it's all good yeah he
doesn't eat kids so um
it's anyway it's not him dude false
alarm oh man I wish this kind of [__]
happened to me about how like fake
Dental
ads but anyway some AI is good and some
eyes is bad and this is bad they're G to
sue him dude you know you can't use
someone's like likeness for a [__]
Grill you can't use someone's likeness
for a teeth cleaning dude for anything
really for that matter dude people are
going to get so sued this AI [__] I
can't even believe
it the laws won't be able to catch up
too you're going to sue they're going to
sue you for AI [__] you're going to go
to court and there's going to be already
by then there's going to be AI lawyers
and we're going to be there and it's
going to be like an AI judge and
everyone's just all [__] and they're
just going to they're going to sue you
uh uh monetarily and you're going to pay
with crypto so it's like nothing ever
happened anyway Tom Hanks
isn't that that's not him um but I do
love how technology has just Tak over I
saw I saw
on Hoda and whatever it is now it Hoda
and Yoda whatever the [__] the news new
Good Morning America it's hoden somebody
used to be hoden Kathy Leah hoden and
[__] uh Lance Bass and Neil degrass
Tyson I don't know who the [__] it is
but um good morning uh good morning and
welcome to Yo Hoda and Ne Tyson we're on
billions of channels billions and
billions of
syndicated um who is it hold I thought
you said something J hod and jeda Bush
no clue
um The Today Show okay so anyway they
were like I just Calvin all of a sudden
took the remote and just goes press it's
so loud and it's on and it's on the good
morning Today Show with Hoda and Yoda
and and uh she's just like Beyonce is it
was her and another woman and then a a
gay black guy and it was like Beyonce if
he's not gay he needs to change the way
he talks but he's gay and so um they
were like Beyonce has a documentary
coming out in
theaters and and then one of the [__]
Hoda girls was like I saw her posted on
Instagram and I watched it over and over
and over and over again and it's like
first of all crazy that there's news
about Beyonce posting something SEC it
goes from the documentary about what's
the movie's about to now the Today's
Show is just talking about what Beyonce
posted and then it's like hey Howa they
didn't watch it over and over again you
watched it once you watched almost the
whole thing once you know what I'm
talking about and you didn't watch it
over and over again and that's fine and
then they like if
Beyonce uh is if this is in theaters and
then the gay black guy was like uh um
Bieber's movie made $99 million when it
came out nobody knew that was going to
Beyonce
could actually surpass that we're
talking $300 million the guy's just
talking out of his ass and I'm sitting
here watching the thing and I'm seething
dude I just get to seething man Calvin
had no idea when he hit that button that
was going to get to see then cuz what
the [__] dude hey guys I want to be like
get a job but this is their
job they're doing this [__] and they got
people outside the window in the back
just
like that [__] thing you know
whatever like TRL started it and now
it's got it all the [__] everyone's in
the back
just they know it's not news they know
it's not even worth talking about
because they got people in the back
distracting you from it they don't even
give a
[__]
how has nobody flashed to them by the
way ever nobody's taken their penis out
nobody's turned around opened up and
showed them the you
know sarlac pit
nobody
um anyway dude uh so I'm watching this
and I get to see then then I turn it off
and it's okay because Calin wanted to
watch big giant Pac-Man on YouTube is
what he called it and so we did we watch
that that's much better than Hoda and no
don't disrespect Hoda you know even
though I disrespected her for about you
know 6 minutes so far um but so it's
just crazy to me how pervasive I guess
or omnipresent God God and I only got an
1100 on my SATs but um and this was back
when you could only get 6 I think you
get like 25,000 now or something but um
so so now I'm like oh crazy how much
like inundated we are God damn it and
only 1110 on the
SATs uh um but I'm firing out three
crazy words like I don't like you know I
obviously learned stuff since the SAT
but I'm just saying that's just
incredible but anyway I get this thing
that's like now everyone's phone alarm
will go off at 2:20 p.m. eastern time on
Wednesday now that was either that's
either today if you're on the patreon
patreon.com citalia or you get it late
that was yesterday now you didn't know
it was going to happen I didn't know it
was going to happen until I did know it
was going to happen I did know it was
going to happen because the news uh
vetting here at congratulations Studios
at super good Studios is AB incredible
and you know this came hot off the
presses it was like Hey dude we got this
just in you might want to talk about it
and I was like I don't think I want to
talk about then I did want to talk about
it because it's like dude everyone's
phone's gonna go off and so um so I'm
thinking oh this is crazy wild right and
I'm like reading about it if you hear a
screeching alert go off in your cell
phone and everyone else is this is by
CNN so you know it's true cuz CNN has
absolutely never lied in the world
right till every day so um the federal
government said it will conu conduct
conduct wh on Wednesday afternoon a
nationwide test of you know this and
[__] anyway the purpose is to ensure
that the systems continue to be
effective means of warning public
emergency whatever they want to test it
you know we get why you understand you
only you're ding bad if you don't and
then it so I texted to my
mommy
and she says
straight up I say why everyone's phone
will alarm I sent her the article she
writes I doubt
it huh like just straight up just
probably didn't even read it just
negating what I'm I'm trying to help her
out she says doubt it dude and he got to
see then dude but he loves his mommy he
really does I love my mommy but how
funny is that though it's
funny
um technology is crazy my mom sends me
the craziest [__] dude she like check
this out it's like you
know it's it's it's a on Instagram but
it's a it's a Tik Tock thing with a like
that somebody uploaded on Instagram and
it has a Tik Tok Watermark you know
that's like such a mom thing to send and
it'll be like somebody that's just like
my mother came through and the reason I
always love your mother and I'm just
like Mom I love you you don't have to
send me a 60-second
video of
like some guy some woman in Tallahassee
just talking
about eight reasons to love your mother
cuz she was and here's the number one
reason is always in these videos cuz she
was always there no matter what and it's
like yeah my mom was always there for
that no matter what but also some
moms weren't always there no matter what
so in essence what I'm saying is don't
make that
video that's why like this why I love
when the when the government is like
when when like a big catastrophe happens
and and they're like we will make it
through and we have made it through and
we will persevere and it's like yeah
except for the fact that except for the
people that
didn't I don't like when they say that
it it it it makes me feel bad for the
other what about the other people I want
the government to on say it be like he
we didn't all make it dude and that
sucks we failed hundreds or thousands of
people because they always come out the
president always comes on during a
natural disaster and it's like and we
will prevail and we have prevailed and
we have prevailed what do they mean all
n billion of us it's going to take more
than a tsunami to knock us all
out one tsunami in India is going to
[__] who who 2,000 people died yes but
we made it through dude if one of those
2,000 people were the people like like
we made it 911 we made it dude what
about all the [__] dude if you knew
somebody that was dead in the building
and they say hey we got through it how
about at home when it's your dad and
you're like no we
didn't no we
didn't but we just hit the hard-hitting
facts you know and we talk about what we
talk about and people still get mad dude
I made a joke on this podcast hey why
don't people understand comedy is comedy
I don't get it I don't get why people
don't understand comedy is comedy okay
this is a comedy podcast I'm always
talking [__] out of my
anus okay and I put up a thing I I
talked about um how we shouldn't how we
should you how we shouldn't look out for
the environment because somebody was
going to hit the red button and kill us
all anyway with a nuke okay and everyone
was like really [__] irresponsible
dude I put it on an Instagram clip go
look I was like really responsible this
is the message you want to send your
kids and I'm like that a
comedian yeah anyway dude it's so
insane so go get your teeth clean is
what Tom Hanks is trying to say and I
agree with him
frankly
um I agree with them I agree with
them I talked about this already didn't
I I did on we got a Caren on the golf
course right now didn't I already talk
about this godamn I talked about it on
this is even where you're [__] I'm
not getting a fight at a golf this guy
so much anger management dude like
just has been I I I know he's dealt with
his anger issue because of how he's
trying to hold it together and he goes 0
to 60
in4 the outfit is eh locking in 1996 so
here we go here and you can complain
goodbye I'm not complaining you're the
one
no you're the one that approached me and
I asked you to no long to speak you took
her ball here's the deal that woman
needs to shut the [__] up right okay two
she's only going to make when two dudes
are barking at each other hey women
chill you know why you going to get your
man beat up or you going to get your man
catch a case either one it's going to
happen because you just exacerbate God
damn it I got 11 to 10 on my SATs and
and it's crazy that you'd have no idea
but you're going to exacerbate the issue
and it's going to lead into [__] some
pandemonium oh for [__] sake are you
kidding
me
1110 don't speak to me coming over me
you took her ball bro you dude lady lady
that's me me I turn it into Jerry Lewis
if that happens to me lady quiet your
mouth and the guy goes nuts the guy goes
ham and runs out of his golf cart dude
how [__] is it to get in a fight near
two golf carts for real though anywhere
in the golf you should be in a fight and
you're about to be like all right square
up [__] you see a golf cart
you're like you know what we got to
actually cool out let's go let's take it
somewhere else cuz this is crazy a golf
cart just came by you know we can't get
into this fight in a vicinity of a golf
cart come on dude look here we
go look at him snap if you need money
for a golf
balls [__] boy uh uh uh oh I said 0 to
60 but he did kind of hit one or 2 miles
an hour before that right here off the
Cartal here we go Walter
oh here we
go that's what you been to Heaven [__]
and you would to test God you [__]
come get it [__] stack okay he's
mentally ill oh and then the chicks all
okay you know what he's mentally ill I
actually thought there was going to be
some sort of extra you know thing that
we were going to what you think they
were going to work some [__] out the
guy's so mad oh you know what he's
mentally ill we can't talk to him you
thought you were going to break
through this is the thing that all that
chicks they think they're therapists you
know oh
man
my therapist always wants to talk about
my [__] feelings man and I'm just
like hey can we just [__]
chill it's so annoying
sometimes CU they do
like how do you feel and then you tell
them and then they [__] say how do
you feel about that and you're
like
what what is this are we falling
backwards in a van into a river how many
layers how many levels are we going to
go down let me just tell you hey I'm
pissed next
[Music]
question this is like [__] it's like
it's like Inception
dude hey how do you feel uh you know um
it feels
bad and what what about that though uh
you you know what actually I'm
out me and [__] three
other Tom Hardy and the Asian dude just
me and
Leo how do you feel about that I you
know it's making me sad I guess [__] how
many layer
just and it's so it's like dude it's a
feeling it's just like it's like lady
can we just like you
know I I don't know I always want to get
like when when I get into an argument
with anyone I want to blow my
lid and then chill it's kind of like
busting a nut honestly I want to pop my
top off
dude I mean I just I want to
go ham you understand like when I get
pissed and I'm talking about if I walk
around the the corner and an end table
catches my hip I want to look into the
nearest person's eyes and say Hey [__]
you for having that be
there and I could be at a a [__] Bank
of America dude I don't I I could be
literally somewhere that has nothing to
do that guy who I yell at and look in
his eyes he didn't put the end table
there I don't give a [__] at that moment
I need to pop my [__] top off
okay and here's the deal if the guy's a
good guy take it I take it if I'm out of
the park and somebody gets you know if
they're walking and then uh you know
they look at their phone and a branch
smacks him in the face and I'm nearby
swinging them kettle bells getting real
fancy and someone says hey hey [__] you
for having this Branch hit in my face I
go like this yo bro I get it I eat that
thank you I'll take it that's my whole
sandwich all
right but I can't do that at home so I
got to eat that anger I gotta eat the
anger I gotta keep I gotta eat it myself
right I got to do it myself until it
becomes cancer right because I can't pop
my top off at my I can't who am I gonna
pop my top off at Calvin ruin his life
William way too young Billy grow up and
be so stunted he's five five months old
can't do it at my wife she start crying
who am I going to do it to I you the
amount of times I said to my wife can I
just pop my top off for a little bit and
she goes she says no and I go and I it
makes me more angry dude I'm like just
let me let me [__] bust off
dude you know what I
mean and I just can't I can't under you
know what dude not even that I can't
under no circumstance can I
right under oh oh under no circumstance
can I and I pop my top off and I
couldn't do it at my mommy when I was
growing up couldn't do it at my mommy I
get grounded one time I did one time I
did once one time I pop my top off
dude she said are you ready for bed are
you ready for school are you ready for
school she always you know how many
times I was late to school zero times
dude the thumb to the tip of the finger
zero zero times I was like for school
zero times my mom you ready getting up
for school you get Mom yeah yeah got got
it right and she didn't even get up to
wake me up she called from her bedroom
oh [__] he's cooking she called from her
bedroom hey you woken up oh my dad was
already at work right oh you woken up
Chris yeah yeah I got it I don't hear
the shower oh [__] dude let me pop my
goddamn morning top off right let me pop
my top
off but he's not allowed but one day one
day when he woke up with the crust in
his eye maybe he was up too late
pretending to do homework who knows
maybe he's was watching that [__]
channel in in the middle of the channels
with the with the purple and yellow
wavies and try and catch a tit maybe
that's what he was trying to do but he
woke up and I'm talking about me here
I'm doing a novel he woke up dude and my
mom said you ready yet you in the shower
yet dude I crank that t shower on and in
my head that was all I needed to drown
out me the shower turning on that was
all all all I needed to pretend to
convince myself that this next thing I
say
will drown out my scream and I said yeah
[__] know what I heard
back
nothing
uhoh hey it's worse to hear nothing hey
hey when you yell
yeah [__] to your mom and then you
don't hear
nothing what
oh okay uhoh and what I did was went to
school came back my dad got home from
work and he says Hey so you're
grounded you can't pop your top off you
can't pop your top off so how am I
supposed to get rid of this [__] I got
to go to therapy I got to talk about my
actual feelings oh [__] well dude this
just in I don't like doing that so I'm
all uncomfy huh so I gotta be all
uncomfy staring at the [__] computer
through Zoom ah he's all uncomfy he's
got to do it right and that's the quote
unquote right thing to do but is it the
easy thing to do [__] no
dude
God so he doesn't pop off the top and he
has to talk about the you know he's in
his men's group right I'm in a men's
group I'm in the I'm in the I'm in my
Therapies
oh like right now I kind of want to pop
my top off because I hear stuff right
outside of my
door they should be quiet right but I
can't pop the top off I got to sit here
and I got to pretend like it's not
happened I got to talk I got to keep on
talking I got to do this monologue even
though it's eating me inside and you
don't know it because you can't hear
it but I can yeah
dude and that's why this guy is going to
live I tell you right now this guy who
just yelled at somebody at a golf course
at a at a golf course yelled them at the
[__] two uh at the golf cart he he
called him a [__] stack dude that put
years on his life when you get to a
point where you rip your shirt off like
your Hulk Hogan and scream [__] stack to
another grown man you just added days to
your
life me
I'm already on borrowed
time I can't say
[__] anyway
dude it is what it is if you want to
test God come and get it [__] stack and
I agree with them
100% I agree with him
100%
bro these
guys from the NBA
remember that kawh Leonard there's a new
guy Jaden Hardy that's like a fake AI
Name by the way
but dude so remember the Kawhi lard
laugh I mean it's like if you rewind it
it would be like Satan is are a leader
you know
if you rewound that it would just be
like is our leader be above the
teachings of abuk learn the teachings of
Baba
Duke my son's crying so there's the I'm
just kidding Calvin did you hear him in
the
headphones okay so kawh Leonard and then
here's the Jaden Hardy laugh which is
the new [__]
dude it
is I don't know oh dude
I mean dude that was a [__] I've
never heard a loud giggle
before let's play it
again that one probably still reign
supreme
[Music]
dude Ela is our savior and
[Laughter]
uh dude like he just saw a big
baby let me tell him to be quiet hey
guys hey hey guys can you be not
here thank
you he says it he said it a bunch though
right oh no oh no this is
me I know me when I say hey can you guys
be
quiet I know that's my wife
me pretending I'm not mad me pretending
I'm not mad when I hear it and then my
wife right
here I don't
know I'm like
this excuse me can you guys be quiet and
then just my
wife I don't
know anyway
dude
[Music]
um I guess ice spice almost got burned
or
something you know the thing about ice
spice is I'm officially too old that's
the thing about ice
spice did she actually get
burned oh almost
imagine she farted and it just [__]
that would be the best also she's
Annie why is anyone acting like she's
not friends with Daddy
warbox hey I
spice you're Annie it's all good she's
got good music probably I have no
idea
um
what the [__]
um more khed news
here it's a hard knock life for us it's
a hard knock life for us dude
khed I have two Drake songs on my new
album he
writes and just
leaves just this guy's nuts bro he just
has a he's walking with Drake where the
[__] is this
anyway and he's he's got a a a
thing holding it God this guy's a he's a
genius idiot dude like this guy every
time I think he's dumb I also think but
he [__] knows what's up
dude he's
unbelievable oh wait dude that's right
right the ice spice Dunkin Donuts ad
with uh isn't uh I love look I'm a big
fan of Ben Affleck he's in the
thing Ben
Affleck Ben
Affleck here dude I'm already signed in
I hate when they do this
dude
here here we go here it
is Big promotion made me brand
ambassador we got to come oh wait this I
love Ben Affleck [__] love him dude
is he this Boston or is he like I'll do
the commercial if I can do a little bit
of a character I mean he's so Boston I
Saw The Departed the other day and they
[__] all tried to do it that accent
so hard things are not going to going
well things are D going going well big
promotion made me brand ambassador we
got to come up with a drink name but
it's not easy right nowadays with social
media the kids it's got to be authentic
it's weird because Ben Affleck doesn't
act like that and he's playing himself
but he's like playing a guy that should
be wearing a pinky ring how are people
going to connect you with Duncan I'm a
Duncan girl I'm not seeing it ice spice
my fans are to munchkin where you going
with this ice spice munchkins drink I
got an idea collabs like they do right I
spit B with you we're called Vanilla Ice
spice here I am I'm with Duncan you
go that's kind of funny the end why
aren't commercials funny though b b you
go
um
why is Ben Affleck and Ice Spice in a
commercial it's just so weird like
they're like that somebody from
marketing was like all right look here's
what we're going to do we're going to
get everyone we're going to get the
older crowd because this guy is a
respected filmmaker and actor he was
nominated for Oscars and then we're also
going to get whoever this [__] Annie
chick is that you know how that's to
that talk right ice spice is crazy dude
is she the first gray person I'm not
even trying to be like don't come at me
right now but she's the first gray
person right cuz I thought I was kind of
gray but then I saw
her I mean come
on is she black or white I have no idea
that's the thing dude when I people say
I don't like when people say I don't see
color you know because it's like I I
think what should happen is you should
see the color of the person respect it
but with ice spice hey I don't see color
and that's true it's a hard knock life
for us it's a hard knock life also did
she say Munch in that [__]
ad okay that
means eat
[__] I know but they got her because
she says munchin it's called munchkins
so really it's like they're [__]
flavored dnut holes is what it
is hey yo hey Ben Affleck hey look they
wanted me to be brand
ambassador hey they wanted me to be
brand ambassador you know what I mean I
don't know I just pop out the car get
over there anyway what the [__] I spice
how's going on that everyone's like uh
Ben cut cut Ben um what the [__] can you
uh maybe just be you ah you know I'm
from Boston Boston guys always want to
tell you they're from Boston you know
they won't for a [__] second let you
forget it even actors they'll be in
other movies they'll be in like King
Arthur and Mark Wahlberg will have a
part and he'll be like he'll just slip
it in ah it's over ah yes yes the
problem is it was different he said
something else when we were over in the
courtyard and and you're like oh yeah
he's from bos yeah I know this is King
Arthur but he's from B right he's from
Boston ah yeah that yes yes that's right
that's absolutely beautiful and we love
we love that that's great we've going
we're going to have to take it to the
town let's meet in the courtyard
huh oh yeah yeah that's right he's
playing the guy who gets beheaded but
also he's I for how could I forget he's
from he's from Boston right he's a
Celtics yeah go Celtics yeah yeah
[__] die hard
right um are there other commercials
with them in it I think there are they
don't ever just film One commercial too
they do like 900 that's it goes
um cuz they call it a what do they call
it a a campaign or something and Ben
Affleck Ben Affleck Ben
a
Affleck here we go um here's another one
dunan is very Advanced science algebra
formulus you know there's a lot that
goes into this you can't just come up
with a name I I I don't like funny
commercials cuz here's why I imagine
everyone behind the camera the whole
time when they're shooting like
this let him go and I just want to
[__] no raise munchkin drink what
what would that be you put the munchkin
in the Duncan I think I got
replaced I mean who wrote that you
know Duncan is very Advanced science
algebra formulas you know there's a lot
that goes into this you can't just come
up with a name I spray munchkin drink
what would that be you put the munchkin
in the Duncan I think I got replaced
that's a cool song I want to hear more
of it why is
uh so there's Donuts in a drink what the
[__] is going on
dude um wow Ben Affleck is in so many
Dunkin Donuts commercials oh dude I hope
he's
getting so much money and you know she
is
too um Dukes of Apollo is so good uh
that is a
hauler that they wanted me to do they I
think they said sing it and I'm not
singing it because I mean like you know
uh there's limits to this [__] there's
limits to this [__] but yeah uh go to my
P if you want to purchase a 10-word
ad uh or whatever you call that thing
this guy paid for holler. bab
christalia sorry
my my uh Billy was crying I want to make
sure he was okay
um Trump fraud trial underway and
um
apparently
uh the lawyer I guess no lawyers want to
work with him cuz he like doesn't pay or
whatever it is but like the lawyer
forgot to check the
box to get him a jury trial now oh dude
now if he loses he's going to be
so it's rigged it's
rigged and it's
like oh you wanted to jur so bad because
there are at least people who are on his
side that are people but but the
government is not on his side and judges
are probably not on his side
too he's [__] and the lawyer who just
kind of is like a
hotwoman is just like she looks like
she'd be like yeah I'll do it like she
definitely eats the [__] munchkin
drink um but she forgot to check the box
to ask for dude women saw this and they
go like this she set us
back she set us back Trump women go like
this she's [__] this [__] woman
set us back cuz she did because she
forgot to text a box that she wanted a
[__] jury Tri and now you don't get
to go back you know you don't got to be
like Oh I'm sorry can I actually no you
don't dude now there's got to be a judge
and uh he's going to preside not in
Trump's favor because the system is
riged because everyone and I'm not
saying he should or should I don't know
the [__] case at all um but the boy
speaks the truth you know so that's what
happens that is pretty
crazy
um unreal
dude uh here's another sign that the
future is
messed uh what I mean this can't be re
this is yeah you know what makes sense
3D printed steak
um and so what we have here our specials
are we have a uh steak that is 3D
printed um and it comes with the idea of
mashed potatoes and you can also get uh
some virtual broccoli and you will leave
so hungry
[Music]
um could soon be 3D printed that's come
here your steak could soon be 3D printed
yum
that's if you live in Europe Israeli
company redefined meat has struck a
partnership with importer geraldi meat
this is so czy European distribution of
its new meat steak cuts so it's not
startup is hoping to establish its
products as an alternative to
conventionally produced meat I'm so
hungry oh just seeing those machines go
back and forth
make making that steak appear out of
nowhere God that just gets me salivating
dude operates large scale scale meat
printers at it oh dude no nothing makes
me hungrier than hearing the words meat
printer oh [__] dude hey you got a meat
printer at your house oh let's do the
barbecue there hold on N dude yeah my
Grill's fine but my friend Bruce has got
a meat printer holy [__] you take one
One Taste of these [__] virtual Meats
head
south of T what do you want a ribey or
what do you have whatever you want I
just [__] put it in the computer I
plug it in what do you want you want
duck as well as in a new Factory in the
Netherlands you know what's funny is man
the why do they make it look like how it
looks just make it look like
anything make it look so different you
can it'll still taste the same company's
3D printers project yonel explains how
how it was imagine how bad the first
ones are that they made when I want to
make my steak I can I have a a library
of a few different slabs I can choose
each one of them and I can adjust it
accordingly I can Define the amount of
marbling yeah this guy the internal fat
or the external fat and then now I can I
can start and go and print it and
produce it so I'm putting it this is my
que this is my my timeline for today I
know that in an hour or something from
now I will need to refill the the
machine with new new material but now
directly into the printing process and
you can see how how the process start to
build layer by layer and then you eat it
and everybody gets cancer immediately um
so we print the meat the company makes
its products from ingredients including
soy and pea protein looks kind of good
fruit nutritional yeasts and coconut fat
co-founder and chief executive
said red meat was launching T and
stripin stakes in the past two years we
have been working deeply on
understanding meat and what makes meat
so exciting and we identified a few
components that we can recreate from
plants and have the same exact
performance as the tissue of animal meat
performance combination of additive such
a [__] the exact feeling your I'm eating
a meat just being like ah what a
gorgeous performance experience God this
is a gorgeous coming from an animal
without the use of the
animal plant-based meat Al turn you
still got to cook it increasingly
popular in recent years you ever have a
a [__] um what do you call it
impossible Burger it it it's good but it
doesn't taste like meat and then
also it's really bad for
you hey just eat the
cow hey print your
meat isn't that a doesn't that isn't
meat printing another uh word for
masturbation man startup Nova meat M
I'll be right down I'm printing my meat
is also using 3D printing technology to
manufacture vegetarian Stakes but the
early hype about plant-based meat
Alternatives has ebbed as inflation and
recession worries have driven some
customers back cheap animal meat product
$400,000 companies such as us beyond
meat have cut their sales outlooks
redefine meat however has big
Ambitions it's new meat is currently
available in Israel Britain the
Netherlands and Germany everyone in
those countries will be dead within 10
years this is
crazy um it also will be for sure
cheaper and so every store is going to
have it like McDonald's is going to just
be [__]
fake ass
meat printed
Meat Man remember when we were kids some
of you are probably kids even still you
listen to this podcast you shouldn't be
but how crazy the world is now from then
when I was 17 nobody had a cell phone
when I was 19 every everybody had a cell
phone okay I went to Canada to do a
movie for a month or two I came back
everyone had a [__] cell
phone everyone was hot on playing snake
remember snake [__] that game was so
addictive right just trying to eat that
little ball and the [__] Nokia
right and uh now I mean if you had told
me when I was 19a they're going to be
able to print Stakes I mean I wouldn't
have believed you
but this is crazy what's out there
that's going to happen that we don't
know about wow remember when we were
like hey by the way what's up with
[__] flying cars dude remember the
future meant that let's do that before
he start printing my [__]
meat um this is my favorite tweet I
think or it was on Facebook or something
uh Donald Trump when he wrote I am
pleased to report for those that care
this is a while ago but that I just won
the senior Club Championship and then
impr us rights must be over 50 years old
like you didn't want them to think he
was you know at Bedminster Trump
National Golf Club shooting over a round
of 67 now some people will think that
sounds low but there is no hanky
lanky many people watch plus I am
surrounded by Secret Service agents not
much you can do even if you wanted to
and I don't oh for some reason I am just
good a good golfer
athlete I have won many Club
championships and it's always a great
honor Jesus brag the whole
time what is hanky lank I I I know I
know Hanky
Panky um shooting around of 67 now some
people think that think that sounds low
so he's saying like I know people are
gonna think I'm cheating
right wow it's
hilarious but there was Secret Service
agents around him like they were going
to be like sir sir sir hit it at it Li
hit it as it lies like there like there
like yeah he's down there in the in the
brush make sure he hits it as it lies
and doesn't touch the grassp around it
please
uh-huh you know they got to listen to
him he's the president hey don't tell
anyone I'm moving I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm
placing it out of the [__] what is it
the sand trap
um wow that's great that
is that is e Sensei um let's look at
some
uh I gotta Tik Tok
here oh this is so [__]
here come
on please play please play thank you
please please
play so [__] so [__] twisting it too
many
roundout
no come
on dude hey guy get a car so [__]
dude this
sound oh my God bro the sound that sucks
this thing sucks dude what is it [__]
1905 so loud dude get get Bluetooth with
it
why is it so sharp in the front there
dude if someone if he crash he's going
to stab someone in the just spear
someone's
heart wow I I hate this thing dude you
know I hate this thing so
much look at this [__] what is this [__]
oh what is that look at this you got to
do that to drive it or something that
sucks how much is this
thing
$110,000 what is this
[__] oh my god dude that thing sucks
dude look at this I love vintage cars
where can I get this wish I had an
opportunity to ride one guy writes if
your comment gets at 100,000 likes I
will fly you in and we will drive this
together the most rich guy thing ever to
do
um why do people like this people love
[__] [__] like that and I'm just like
get Bluetooth you know I love [__] [__]
though dude God I love [__] [__] oh
dude come on the guy on the thing with
the are
you the the longest [__] Golf Club of
all time he's on a PL he's on a
table
D imagine seeing a guy
up guys got to bring the table around to
[__] shoot oh dude hand me
my guy dragging the big ass golf bag
it's it's so long just dragging on the
ground dude
[Laughter]
so come on
[__] dude how'd he hit it that's
pretty good
so [__] dude I would fall off that
thing so hard when I did it I dude
hitting it like that and just being like
I sliced
it got to bring the T got to bring the
table the high table what do you call it
high CH what do they call High Top
around um that's
amazing uh anyway that's it dude so
watch the
um yeah I watch the uh um uh YouTube
episode that's it for the YouTube
episode that's what I'm trying to say
that's it for the YouTube episode if you
want to watch the uh regular version or
the the patreon version the edited the
unedited I mean it's not regular and
it's not edited it's the longer version
unedited and it's the uh
uncut uh version of this episode that is
longer and it's called Uh and you get
that at uh patreon.com christalia and uh
like And subscribe you can also if you
if you get the patreon that's just six
bucks you get all of the backlogged
episodes that we've done for over 2
years I think at this point so there's
like 30 something episodes that uh do
one a month that is uh only for the
patreon members we appreciate you so you
can do that and then you can also uh do
uh leave a comment that'd be great leave
a comment my babies we love you
chris.com thanks
[Music]
guys
[__]